permettre à tous de jeunes et dignement
c'est le pari de ses membres de la
croix-rouge à l'ipa ils sont près de 700
à observer ce mois de ramadhan pour des
migrants sur la route de l'exil dans des
conditions précaires ce moment de
sacrifices de prière et de partage est
rendu particulièrement difficile le
gouvernement bosniaque a décidé de les y
aider en mettant en place plusieurs
aménagements dans un camp qui accueille
près de mille migrants hollande ans
promène tout démarre mais je dois dire
que nous avons la cuisine ouverte qui
est beaucoup les migrants à passer le
temps pendant leur séjour à l'ipa c'est
aussi une opportunité de pouvoir
cuisiner leurs plats traditionnels ce
qui a une grande importance pour eux
pendant leur séjour dans ce centre
temporaire ou plus ils ont plutôt
tendance à faire du pain des soupes ou
des galettes farcies des moments de
partage simple qui revêt une
signification particulière pendant le
ramadan ainsi la croix-rouge adapter ses
horaires de distribution alimentaire
objectif que chaque migrant puissent
consommer le symbole le repas pris avant
le lever du soleil et l'iftar celui du
soir qui coupe le jeune quotidien nous
faisons tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir
pour garantir que les personnes qui
souhaitent jeûner pendant ce mois de
ramadan reçoivent tout ce dont elles ont
besoin
le seoul un dîner chaud et tout ce qui
est nécessaire
non en plus des repas les bénévoles ont
mis en place une tente de prière un
moyen de créer une intimité qui manque
cruellement dans ces abris de fortune le
23 décembre dernier le camp de l'ipa a
été ravagé par un incendie
l'union européenne avait alors augmenté
de 3,5 millions d'euros
son assistance humanitaire dans le pays
une aide pour le moment insuffisante
face à une situation parfois critique
dans les camps de bosnie herzégovine